of UFO sightings over United Kingdom to
be released for the first time that's
exciting but here's the thing it's not
this story hmm it's not this story let
me show you guys what the story really
is all right it's this story UFO
sightings in North America jumped to
nearly 6,000 in 2019 Wow and this is
this is from January I mean this is this
this is new news and then we have this
story here which is also from just last
week the UFO sightings that pushed the
UK to take flying saucers more seriously
now I will tell you all I'm a skeptic
man I don't I don't play games you know
aliens come in and you know whatever you
know I will say though there's been a
weird trend going on and one of the
reasons I really want to talk about UFOs
more and is why this show is great
because now I can know is that no for
real I mean we've had the Navy now
releasing documents there was one story
I don't think I have it pulled up I
should have where they said they're
concerned about national security if
they release too much of too many of
these documents but I got to say this
what too many people go wild I don't
know I don't know I don't know they're
worried that like the documents the Navy
has on UFOs might compromise us
technology and security or something
here's the thing man I've been I've been
asked myself why is it that we're having
an uptick in UFO sightings we're having
acknowledgement from the Navy now we're
having acknowledgement from the United
Kingdom yeah that's huge why is it
becoming such a big news now could be it
could simply be that the more people
talk about it the more interest is
drummed up and will start just like a
fad you know where if people are
interested in this stuff it gets better
clicks it makes more money then people
are gonna jump all over it so that
that's it could be nothing and then the
more interest there is there's the more
pressure on governments to actually
release documentation I'll tell you this
though you know I know aliens aren't
real
well I'm sorry I phrased that wrong you
know I know aliens aren't visiting earth
and interacting with the governments
there's no conspiracy no because if that
was Donald Trump would not be able to
keep his mouth shut
hahaha that's not a good point but it
but that's like it's like a typical joke
like you think Trump he'd get an office
and be like wow aliens are real you just
see we just say it
that's what khofifah means yeah that was
the secret what is CoV F come observe
very friendly no no that
extraterrestrials frequenting Earthlings
name Oh
come observe very friendly extra sales
what did I say frequently break
frequenting or frequenting boom-boom all
right so uh let's actually let's
actually do this um let's let's rate
this is actually a pretty short story so
let's get some the facts here they say
from Fox News reported UFO sightings by
the British public will be published
online for the first time the Royal Air
Force ran a UFO unit for 50 years but
shut it down in 2009 after coming to the
conclusion that none of the reports
offered evidence of a real threat
according to the Sun although reports
were previously provided to the
country's National Archives the British
publication reports that they'll be
placed online following a Freedom of
Information Act request by the PA news
agency smokes a spokesman for the RAF
said it had been assessed that it would
be a it would be better to publish these
records rather than continue sending
documents to the National Archives and
so they're looking to put them on a
dedicated gov dot UK webpage members of
the public will now have a chance to
view information about such incidents
and make their own judgments there is
now a clearance process taking place and
it's expected that they'll be published
online sometime in the next two months
in response to the Freedom of
Information request the raf reportedly
labelled the files as comprising
entirely of correspondence with members
of the public alright that actually
sounds producer pointing but yeah they
say giving them given the massive public
interest in the subject I'm pleased that
these files will be released and made
available online Nick Pope who used to
investigate UFO sightings for the
country's Ministry of Defence told the
PA news agency when I worked on the
Ministry of Defence UFO desk we didn't
find definitive proof of
extraterrestrial visitation but there
were so many bizarre and unexplained
sightings that we didn't entirely rule
it out I'm gonna cue up the next story
but you know I'm gonna do that I'm gonna
do the very obvious the very obvious and
cliched I think for the most part these
sightings were just military tuk and I
think one thing that may be happening is
that you know we're seeing the u.s.
start to publish the records and
acknowledge these things we're seeing
the UK do it probably because the
technology from the 60s is no longer
relevant you know there's no great Cold
War threat
and so these governments were working on
these projects in secret now they're
probably like hmm yeah we just tell
everyone
well no no when I got to tell everybody
about the weapons we have no not the
weapons but like sure the the Flying
Saucer
was something we were working on well
maybe it wasn't a flying saucer I don't
know maybe it was like the experiments
don't matter the projects don't exist
anymore there's no real threat to
national security if the project
literally doesn't exist in technology
and pan out yeah it's really funny too
about the whole UFO thing is like drones
like quad copters yeah when you you
could you could easily make a quad
copter look like a like a UFO and fly
around that's true nobody would care
well that's that leads me to think it's
like this you know six thousand new
sightings you know what this is just
people probably just trying to get
attention oh yeah well no I mean a lot
of that is just people knowing that
there's an increased interest in UFOs
right now or over the past year yeah
over the past year and you know I'm want
to be one of the people that that saw
something or maybe it's like you know
maybe they did see something no you know
it's that what's it what's that thing
called where it's like you buy a VW but
you buy walks back in the Nellis and you
see Volkswagens everywhere yeah it's
like a confirmation bias you know yeah
there's probably a lot of people who are
like someone tells you mm-hmm
oh you don't this reminds me of a crazy
story let me tell you about this this
legend good let me hear this I'm gonna
I'm gonna ruin it I'm gonna ruin it I'm
gonna ruin it but it's basically like
the story about how when Christopher
Columbus was first sailing to the
Americas and he like came to the
Caribbean you know the story is that
none of the Native Americans could
actually see his ships their sailing on
the horizon they're getting closer and
closer they couldn't see them because it
didn't exist in their minds right like
they'd had no concept of what a ship was
this big they had no concept of a fleet
so when they looked on the ocean their
brains and even process it and the story
goes that a wise man one of the elders
who would sit on the beach all day and
like study the waves in the ocean
eventually noticed the wave patterns led
to these objects and he said hey there's
something there and then he wouldn't
told everybody and then once he
explained what you need to see they
could see it you ever hear the story no
it's interesting about but here's what I
believe it's true you know why
I love doing this trick where I'll be
driving in a car with my friends and
then I'll when I see a cell tower I'll
ask them look in that direction
what do you see they'll say nothing oh
you don't see anything like no I'll bet
there's trees that's the ground in the
street like around the highway there's
like there's a tree right there what's
right there I don't know what are you
pointing at this guy I'm like do you
don't see anything and they can't tell
me you did that tiny did it to you I
thought it did you yeah who's on the way
to the skate park in Miami and you were
like where yeah yeah I'm like what do
you see what you see like because here's
the thing right you know I noticed this
because when I started working with more
live stream tech yeah I became very
aware of all the cellular technology the
towers the antennas and things like that
and so it was like the first time I was
looking for antennas and I was trying to
figure out what they were based in their
shape because this was back in like the
ymax days like that was like an early 4G
technology that was terrible got like 1
megabit but this was the WiMAX antennas
were a different shape many of them were
like round or bulbous and the 3G
antennas were like they're like
rectangles so I look at the tower and
try and see which one you know would
work better and yeah so I would talk to
I would ask somebody like hey you know
take a look and they'd be like what but
what you know do you see if you see any
round antennas or anything maybe I don't
know if you're pointing it I don't and I
look at the cell tower what cell tower
where and I'm like you literally can't
see the cell towers right and so here's
the thing that you know they disguise
cell towers as trees and stuff right you
have you never seen these did all the
time so that's cool they'll paint it
brown and then on top or the antennas
are they'll paint it green people don't
see him it's completely out of their
minds
so this back to the UFO point when you
start showing pictures to people and
saying this is what you need to look for
eventually people are gonna start
thinking about it and then they're gonna
start noticing it now I don't I don't
know if that Christopher Columbus thing
is real you know for all I know that's
just like an urban legend or whatever
like what all this is gonna come out and
then in a year or two once the the
general public you know it starts to get
you know used to the idea of seeing
these things and knowing what to look
for then all of a sudden
UFOs are gonna be everywhere yeah well I
mean look you see that video you know
you know Casey nice debt right have you
seen that thing where he had the giant
drone and he was like being towed on a
snowboard yeah and it lifted him up yeah
and put some you put some fancy dressing
on that and let's say it's a UFO dude
it's a flying saucer unidentified flying
object you know but I mean like
literally you look at a flying saucer
and people would see it in the sky this
gray severe what it's great disc
floating they book what is it
it's a quadcopter man we had helicopters
back then true how big you know we had
helicopters how hard would it have been
back then you know we had we had
jetpacks and we had there was this thing
it was a platform you stood on mm-hmm
and it had a high power you know like
dual blade in it and it was a platform
you could stand on and press a button
and it would you do on it we also had
jet packs with euros like this late 60s
70s but the rate you know why they
didn't want to do it I watched on
dangerous exactly helicopters were a lot
safer so the idea was like how can we
get you know we want our soldiers to fly
what can we do so we experimented with
jump Jets like you know rocket packs jet
turbine stuff and like like small jets
and there was one guy who had there's a
platform you stood on like a handlebar
yeah and they were like it transports
one person it's really small it's really
dangerous it's hard to secure so just
did seemed like a good idea yeah and a
lot of them had a flight time with like
a half an hour so then they were like
helicopters can have you know machine
guns mounted inside of them they can
carry multiple people it can be secured
you know let's go the helicopter yeah
but imagine back then in like the time
of the UFOs when they're researching
look we knew helicopters like I don't
know the helicopter was invented was
actually I think is like the 40s or
something
maybe early 50s but we have a general
idea of how these propellers work and so
we had like you know Chinooks like the
dual prop thing I think that's what it
is I'm making the name wrong so how hard
would have would it have been for them
to make a quadrotor like we have today
flying around at every Park yeah that's
true yeah so he's not too difficult and
so they would lie to the public that's
what I think but I will tell you I want
the world to be more fun and exciting so
I'm gonna play a game with you let's
let's jump to this story from from
January 8th ok UFO sightings in North
America jumped near to
6,000 ABC News reports there was a rise
the number of North Americans who looked
up into the sky in 2019 and found
something that didn't look like a bird
or plane the national UFO Reporting
Center which tracks calls and messages
from people around the u.s. and Canada
about strange sightings in the sky
reported that it received five thousand
nine hundred and seventy-one sightings
in 2019 a jump from 3395 and 2018 now is
that out of sight out of mind like I was
describing or is that more aliens coming
to Earth no it's the rise of drones
right right seriously it's probably just
drought and everyone's getting drones
you can get a drone for like ten bucks
you know it's Tom man hold on hold on
I'm trying to make the world more
exciting for people I know but I'm
trying mate I can't help it let's all
right let's be a little bit they say
Peter Davenport who runs the independent
organization that's based in Davenport
Washington said he couldn't explain why
more people called about seeing flashing
white lights fireballs dicks disc shake
dicks JP disc shaped objects or other
oddities in 2019 he couldn't are you
kidding me we literally just debunked
the whole thing it's it's it's it's a
the Maverick Pro congratulations right
it's it's it's Casey Neistat flying
around on his drone one of the mysteries
of UFO ology is there is a fluctuation
the number of reports over the years he
told ABC News in a phone interview some
years it's been low but it's gotten
higher recently California led the
country last year with the most number
of UFO observations to the site 485 in
total an increase of 182 sightings from
2018 Florida came in second with 385 in
2019 which was a hundred and fifty-six
more than the previous year according to
UFO Reporting Center data Washington
came in third yeah we get it as a
Devonport site takes reports from
callers and online submissions many of
which are anonymous and lists them with
as much detail as possible for example
on April 15th and men and his girlfriend
reported they saw a formation in the sky
near Bakersfield California
we witnessed three unidentified objects
one in the middle of being the larger
escorted by the two smaller unidentified
objects one to the left and one to the
right having no lights and no sound and
dark colored objects heading southeast
traveling at an unknown speed and
disappeared into the clouds beyond sight
the report said
Davenport said he does not investigate
any of the claims he collects and
some of the sightings may have been the
same object that was seen by multiple
people Ric Feinberg Feinberg a spokesman
for the American Astronomical Society
emphasized the U and UFO stands for
unidentified and many people are unaware
of astronomical goings-on in space on
any given day for instance Jupiter and
Venus were more visible to Earth last
year and they could can stand out in the
night sky according to Feinberg he also
noted that SpaceX launched 180 news
satellites into space last year and
those devices have lit up the night
skies if you're not keeping up with the
news and not familiar with the skyline
you might mistakenly see an unidentified
flying object
it may be unidentified to you but known
to others
I am yeah and I think the the actual
simple solution is people playing with
drones now you know look when they
talked about the the two objects with no
lights and the big object in the middle
it's like come on man my god military
exporter so uh I scored or something you
know exactly tear evey achill it's good
you don't know what it is but I get it I
mean they're not saying aliens yeah but
here's a more fun idea that's because it
has no sound it's like they have stealth
flight well let's let the abilities that
they could fly it right without anyone
knowing about it yeah low sound maybe
yeah but let's have more fun okay well
here's the more fun conspiracy crazy
idea okay what if what if what's
actually going on is that then the
governments did contact aliens a long
time ago hmm the crashing was at Roswell
it was real okay and the aliens came
down and said yo one of our homies
crashed we made peace with the aliens
but they said listen your world is
fractured between different states and
different ideologies and if we announce
ourselves it will be chaos but we bedlam
your civilization will collapse so we
cannot announce but the time is drawing
near and if the aliens want to truly
reveal themselves they have to very
slowly start appearing more and more the
news starts talking about UFOs more and
more the governments are releasing
documents not not today not tomorrow not
a year not two years maybe in five or
ten we've become so used to seeing and
hearing about these things that
eventually it's just a slow rollout
where no one really cares to be honest I
would love that
I know but
not true I want to I want to meet an
alien yeah a lifetime that'd be awesome
yeah but here's the thing about aliens
man you know we we we evolved in very
specific ways we did on a very specific
planet sure no we've got a certain
percentage of oxygen yeah I think one of
the one of the things that's often not
really talked about and that could be
wrong so I'm not a physicist as to why
you not Fermi's paradoxes no it's
basically it's a thought experiment as
to why we haven't found aliens yet or
intelligent life like if the universe is
so big certainly we would have found
something right we haven't as far as we
know earth is the only planet I mean
unless that the government's are lying
and the aliens are secretly you know
spin around above us which I really
doubt yeah so there's a bunch of as much
of ideas like every civilization that
becomes intelligent watch itself out you
know like humans in nuclear war unless
they've become a type two civilization
or I think know type one Oh type one
yeah type one when they unify the planet
and you know or I guess technically
maybe maybe you're right I don't know at
which point because a type one might
still die for some reasons but there's
like the great filter theory that life
can only reach a certain point before it
just watch itself out but one thing I
don't I don't I don't hear talked about
often enough is how we're able to
harness fire you know fusion energy
essentially converting you know chemical
reactions to heat metals to separate
lesser elements and denser you know
molecules and things like that you know
so if you had about a planet full of
like imagine there was a planet with
with no oxygen in the atmosphere and the
life there evolved to survive
specifically in that environment but
they could make fire how would they
create a computer maybe I'm I don't know
I'm not a physicist maybe well our
chemists their computer would be
probably something completely different
than what we consider a computer maybe
maybe we should just discover it we
reuse without carbon-based everything
but that means then what we're looking
for does it makes sense
we're looking for things based on our
physiology in our environment in our
atmosphere mm-hmm so we're like a metal
ship I don't know what if what if they
eventually make some kind of spaceship
that's just a sphere of water they sit
inside
I can I can definitely imagine that yeah
or there could be like you know I think
about it oh you know what about that
that the object that flew through our
solar system that
Wow that weird yeah the long pencil [ __ ]
and they saw a tower shape thing and
they thought it was like relaying
slingshotting around our Sun on purpose
yeah and it was like part of like an
alien and it was like it looks like just
a long straight rock but right I mean it
could be like that's their space vessel
and they're like no if we go near that
planet they'll probably blow us up you
know getting their crazy those humans
maybe know maybe we're just some dumb
hillbilly backwoods planet nobody wants
to interact with that actually does seem
viable also I would suck if aliens were
to look at at Earth right now and they
would probably be like what are what are
these people doing they know no sentence
but they're destroying them so maybe
their planet how how often do you blame
them how often do you go to cows and be
a lot yo cows let me show you my
technology that's that's a good point
you don't and it's crazy that the human
the difference between humans and cows
it's actually not that crazy especially
relative to other life on the planet
like through a human from an ant is way
crazier than a human to a cow yeah like
we're both mammals mm-hmm both species
make milk we got hair yeah oh no we
vocalize but we speak in different ways
yeah so imagine a completely alien
species they're not gonna they're gonna
be anything like we could imagine but
more importantly if we can't even talk
to our own like like you know class or
whatever like mammals yeah like we can
sorta talk to dogs you know I mean sort
of talk to cats we like to think that we
are but like if we if you can't tell
your dog what a street is then how would
an alien tell us what a quantum
multi-dimensional Megadrive is yeah and
they'd be like look you got to
understand like hyper calculus it's like
why would we bother teaching a cow
calculus right it can't do it mm-hmm you
know I mean can barely communicate right
that's a sad sad reality man it's like
ants I watch this in some video where
they were like an ant like a colony of
ants we'll build an anthill at big
Network next to an interstate
superhighway and they will never know
that highway is there it's outside of
their perception they can't come
they can't understand it's entirely
possible there's aliens shooting around
you know past our planet doing all crazy
sorts of stuff you know but we can't
perceive the way in which they you know
function within our universe because
it's like ants to a highway to a car
yeah we're the ants yep so maybe they
have what we would consider to be like
magic powers they could but they
understand how to manipulate reality in
ways who knows yeah it could also be
that you know like any any species
that's capable of traveling you know
these great distances you know with like
taking into consideration time dilation
or like you know whatever that they
would be so advanced it would be like
why would they come here and talk to
cows well there is a theory that says
when we lit the first atom bomb off they
arrived make sure that they don't go
into space that we don't bring nukes
into space and I I heard that we've
never actually brought a nuke into space
because something prevents us from doing
I don't know this is true or not I don't
remember where I read this but
conspiracy online some conspiracy thing
I was watching but it is interesting
that Roswell happened right after you
know yeah
world war two yeah but they're
researching weapons man you know yeah
that's true that's true but and what
what if it's true though what if what if
we light a nuke off in space and it rips
a hole in something that we don't
understand
it creates maybe a black hole it's you
know I'm speculating but but like the
force of a nuclear warhead is is nothing
compared to like the natural phenomenon
of outer space and like universe you
know I mean yeah so the first bombs were
gravity bombs we just dropped them yeah
you know it was later on we started
building the intercontinental ballistic
missiles that actually you know rocketry
and stuff and they put it under that you
know outer space yeah but I'll tell you
what man like how concerned are we with
like I don't know a bow and arrow or a
spear a little bit you know I mean like
you know if someone was aiming one at me
I'd know if you're walking around New
York City and someone points a bow you
know about an arrow at you you'd be like
you'd get down you'd hide right but if
we were entering like you know a
military excursion up against a group of
people with you know just spears and
bows and arrows
we'd be like this is a cakewalk mm-hmm
because our you know our armored literal
like tanks yeah well I would even make a
sound yeah and then one one artillery
shell they're all gone yeah so now think
about a species so advanced they can
travel you know beyond yea light or
whatever they're gonna be alike those
nukes are cute yeah you know for all
like so there was there's one thing I've
heard a lot from like some of these
stories that come out about these former
personnel who have these UFO sightings
yeah one of the things that was reported
and one of the stories I was covering
was that they said the aliens came here
and shut off all of our nukes around the
world as a show of force - like when was
this this was I can't read what story I
was reading so you know I should have
had pulled up but they were basically
saying like the when we when we started
engaging in the escalation of nuclear
tests like you were saying yeah they
they remotely deactivated all of our
warheads and it was done to tell us that
they're useless like if they want to
come here they will we can't do anything
about it but I also think about like why
would they come here and a lot of people
talk about you know if aliens came they
would colonize and like enslave us and
I'm like that's not true dude we don't
do it we don't enslave ants you know I
mean we like just to get rid of them but
it's also like if if we had a choice of
you know mining gold would we go where
it's infested and dangerous you know
maybe we'd fumigate it I guess yeah but
I think it's much more likely that if an
alien species was looking to colonize
and it can expand and terraform you just
go to a dead Rock planet if they could
travel right why would they yeah you
know it's also the potential for
conflict even even look I mean I think
it's fair to say well no as pond affairs
I was gonna say their technology would
probably be not advanced enough to
prevent an explosion you know or just to
protect them maybe it is though you know
maybe they can manipulate space-time
such a degree that they can't even you
know bullets just like disappear once
they get too close who knows who knows
I've no idea maybe they're our fourth
dimensional beings maybe
you